police and paramilitary forces remain on
the streets of jahangir puri two days
after hindu celebrating a religious
festival fought with muslim residents
here police are forcing people to stay
indoors in the predominantly muslim
neighborhood in northwest delhi
muslims can't even move out of their
homes the police isn't acknowledging
what the hindus did while we're hindus
carrying swords in a religious
procession hindu organizations can raise
their slogans we don't have a problem
with that but when we celebrate our
festival do we raise such slogans
outside temples
phone videos appear to show hindus
carrying swords as they held the
procession through the neighborhood on
saturday and another purportedly shows a
muslim man firing at the procession
both sides accuse each other of starting
the violence
the muslims stopped us and asked us to
turn back there is a mosque close by and
when we got there they started firing
and tried to create chaos more than 20
people have been arrested in connection
to the violence 16 of the muslim cctv
footage we are analyzing cctv footage
and other digital evidence based on that
more people were identified they will
also be detained and interrogated
delhi police also said they'll take
action against anyone found guilty
regardless of their religion but not
everyone believes that one lawyer has
filed a petition with the supreme court
asking it to oversee an independent
investigation into the violence it's the
worst religious tension in the indian
capital in two years
in february 2020 fighting between
muslims protesting against the
citizenship amendment act or caa and
hindus who supported it led to the
deaths of 53 people most of them muslims
delhi police rolled during the ntca 2020
rights
has been under the question the supreme
court had admonished the delhi police
for their role for the lack ascetical
approach and their failure on their part
in preventing the rights and that's not
the only petition surrounding recent
tensions that's been submitted to
india's top court a muslim organization
called jamaica has asked the supreme
court to stop regional governments from
bulldozing the homes of muslims
suspected of violence that's after 45
were bulldozed in the state of madhya
pradesh last week following violence
between hindus and muslims that also
occurred as hindu groups were leading
processions through muslim neighborhoods
elizabeth puranam al jazeera new delhi